hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who episode 9 video it was
a little bit James Cameron aliens Meets
The Ring film series meets Shakespeare
be cut because Mark Gatiss any anytime
mark anus rents an episode there's
always some Shakespeare in there careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet and there's a new round of
the Doctor Who giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so let's go
starting with top 5 WTF
Gagan Rassmussen and tells us that we're
not supposed to watch the video that
they open the episode with this is pure
ring it's like don't watch the videotape
you're gonna die in 7 days it had been
so long since I've seen that movie but
instantly when he said that you know
things you can't unsee that's all I
could think about all sudden the doctor
and Cara come climbing out of this
creepy looking well and jump out of the
screen at you but the episode itself was
originally conceived as a found footage
episode that's why we were viewing
things through what looked like a helmet
cam but I mean the doctor explains later
that nobody has helmet cams whether you
love or hate the idea of a found footage
episode I still think the most famous
found footage film of all time is the
Blair Witch Project which I actually did
get to see in theaters but I do give
them bonus points but you know just
because I know doctor who has a very
limited budget when they try things like
this like they try to change the style
of the show the way I thought about it
is is this is kind of like a bottle
episode like an elevator episode
designed to save money so they can spend
more money on the finale so you know
more special effects bigger things
bigger casts that's why there was almost
nobody in this episode like it costs a
lot more money to cast more actors
especially if you have a lot more sets
too so this is like the money saver
episode which is kind of funny if you
know how television is made they even
have their version of Bishop but the
funniest thing in my mind is like when
the doctor starts explaining history to
Clara like through the 38th century so a
lot has happened she's like what
disaster he's like oh don't worry you're
not you're not gonna have to worry about
it you're gonna be long dead by that
time he just holds his finger up just to
guess what time it is like he's guessing
the direction of the wind if you've ever
watched Joss Whedon's Firefly series it
also postulates that in the far future
the world has moved in a much more
culturally Eastern direction on the
number three though meet the Morpheus
machine sleep no more so the idea is is
that they've taken like the eight hours
of sleep that you would usually need and
compressed it into five minutes great
idea right what could go wrong well the
doctor figures out
but like the sleep dust that accumulates
in your eye has actually evolved into
this biological life-form that is now
spreading like a disease because it's
slowly taking over using actual people
for food this is where I feel most of
the complaints about this episode will
come from that whole can see the rest of
the episode I felt like was great but
this is like the one weak point in the
episode you could argue about Mark
Gatiss really brings the Shakespeare in
when the doctor starts quoting Macbeth
just hammering home the idea that trying
to circumvent this really important
biological process leads to very dire
consequences if you've never read the
story of Macbeth let's just say that it
does not end well for him so it will not
end well for those that try to
circumvent sleep I do to say I kind of
like it when doctor who tries to turn
metaphors into literal things it doesn't
always work I mean like you could argue
the conceit of the sleep test is kind of
ridiculous
but the idea of turning this Shakespeare
metaphor into a literal thing is pretty
cool on the number two though there are
no helmet cams so the big reveal is is
that there's been something in the
engine room that's being kept alive that
is hijacking all of the visual feeds but
there are no cameras Oh WTF where's
everything coming from well it turns out
that the sleep dust itself becomes a
visual receptor so when sleep dust
accumulates in your eyes that's when you
start seeing things from people's
perspective but the doctor actually
breaks the fourth wall a couple times
when he looks into camera but most of
the time it's for the benefit of this
third-person camera perspective but the
funniest joke about the whole thing
though is like when he turns to camera
Claire's like wait a minute when do you
sleep doctor and he looks at us the
viewers and he's saying when you're not
looking like he's saying it to Cara but
he's really saying it to us so you can
think of the sleep dust is this sentient
cloud of biological matter that just
like forms itself into physical beings
when it needs to but finally on my
number one WTF moment it literally turns
into the ring' movie at the very end
when Gagan when the professor reveals
that you have already been infected with
the Morpheus process by watching the
tape it's it's not biological at all
it's not a biological infection it's an
electrical one that triggers the
Morpheus process and the Morpheus
process is what causes like the sleep
dust in you to turn into the sentient
thing so if you had not gone through the
Morpheus process or you had
watch this tape you go to sleep you wake
up you have sleep dust you wipe it away
you're good but the minute you undergo
that Morpheus process that
electrochemical process think think of
like your sleep dust is becoming
weaponized so the idea was is that the
sleep dust which has made itself to look
like Gagan Rassmussen was going to
transmit the signal across the cosmos to
infect humanity instantaneously so let
me know in the comments below like how
did you feel about some of the conceits
of this episode or how did you feel
about the twist at the end even if you
had never seen that movie the ring
before I felt like the episode was good
it was a good cautionary tale like you
need to sleep don't don't try to work
your way around that any time you try to
circumvent nature something really
terrible will happen
very typical parable you've seen a
Doctor Who episode and I did see a bit
of Davros in this Gagan Rassmussen
character until it turned out that he
was the dust the whole time I think of
the Sandman as my children the only
complaint I had is just the conceit that
sleep dust in the corner of your eye
would turn into these sentient monsters
they try to consume the human race I
think I would have rather I turned into
a supernatural thing where they turned
the god Morpheus into an actual thing if
you remember last season they actually
kind of did one of these nature versus
man episodes where the forest becomes
sentient and rises up against man that
was actually a very poorly reviewed
episode so I feel like if there are poor
reviews against this week's episode
it'll be for similar reasons sleep dust
in the corner of your eye you know who
could believe that
but the rest of the episode was great
especially considering that this was
like a money-saver episode like it was
intended to be a much smaller
self-contained story but in case you
guys haven't seen it the actors who
plays Missy Michelle Gomez said that
she's gonna be on Gotham she posted this
picture her character's gonna be called
the lady I just think it's gonna be so
awesome
hopefully Sean Pertwee gets some
pictures with her from behind the scenes
it's always funny to see him take
pictures with other Doctor Who actors
again Capaldi our good friends do
because / Cleese father was one of
Capaldi's favorite doctors just to talk
about some of the Easter eggs that I
haven't mentioned already the actor that
played Gagan Rassmussen actually played
the second doctor during an adventure in
space and time that kind of the
docudrama about Doctor Who that they
aired last year when he talks about the
Solarians there was an actual episode
called Doctor Who in the Silurian so
he's just referring back to that and
then of course there's the Shakespeare
episode the Shakespeare Code from the
David Tennant air
if there were any other easter eggs to
guess saw that I didn't mention just
write them below in the comments I
should also say next week really cool a
shielder is coming back for Doctor Who I
don't know what time period it's gonna
take place in but it looks like it's
gonna be really badass in case you guys
haven't seen it there's a whole bunch of
Star Wars stuff that's been happening
the last couple of days I am working on
a flash trailer video gorilla grodd is
coming back next week he is going to
wreck it's gonna be so much fun so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
oh and actually that reminds me about
Doctor Who giveaway winner - named Jack
Bolton you and a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so and get
your contact info while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for the Star Wars trailer that I
just posted and you can click here for
all my other Doctor Who videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight